another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do with the foundation he  should not replace the buckshot in dr  cleff's shotgun shells with any of the  following bird seed confetti cake  sprinkles sawdust or glitter being a  loose cannon ex-goc operative it goes  without saying that dr clef loves his  shotgun and during containment breaches  he's the first to charge in with said  shotgun and face down his anomalous  enemies however as funny as dr bright  thinks it may be he really shouldn't  replace dr cleff's buckshot with any  number of amusing harmless alternatives  while seeing scp-682 get a face full of  cake sprinkles certainly is something if  dr clef needs to spend another week in  traction as a result of it he's gonna  have some serious words for dr bright